[Music]
choking on my tears over here just that
I can't even speak right now that was so
beautiful I'm not always speechless but
right now that was one of the most
moving performances I've seen in a long
time on this show yeah Gwen Stefani and
her hubby Blake Shelton at a loss for
words following bodhi's performance on
The Voice it's unbelievable and every
season just amazing people the moving
moment happened on night one of the
Season 22 finale as Blake's 29 year old
singer Bodie took the stage to perform
gratitude by Brandon Lake
results get out
[Music]
and when host Carson Daly asked Gwen for
feedback she was caught up with emotion
unless you're gonna choose me choking on
my tears over here I
I thought a lot about what it is about
you
um I'm crying um that was so beautiful
but you have like a super power behind
you just that I can't even speak right
now that was so beautiful I wasn't ready
as for bodhi's Coach Blake he felt the
same way I'm not always speechless but
right now that was one of the most
moving performances I've seen in a long
time on this show did you feel more
competitive or less competitive how
would you categorize it more or less
more competitive you got a win for the
household yeah and Blake's got a good
chance of taking home the W this season
three of his singers are left in the
competition while Camila and John each
have one and sadly Gwen is out but you
can bet Gwen's now rooting for her
hubby's team I have a lot of people that
I'm I'm fans of but I would say Bodhi is
um I think he's incredible I really do
maybe him but I like Brayden I like
there's somebody everybody that's left I
they're all incredible this season
marked Gwen's first since she and Blake
became husband and wife but the country
star announced in October next season
will be his last Kyle loved music and I
love I love the voice I love all the
cool things I get to do with my job but
those things are at all take a back seat
now to to
Gwen and the kids and it's just a new
phase of my life and and uh and because
of that I don't feel like I'm is
necessarily putting myself in in the rat
race anymore and for Gwen she just
grateful for the voice and what she got
out of it I never in my lifetime would
picture me doing something like this
it's been one of the most fun things
I've ever done I love being a coach I
love watching the contestants grow I
love having an impact you know super
inspiring for me and then on top of it I
meet like my best friend here that's
gonna be like forever mine
[Music]
thank you